des compositions de végétaux et de forme
dérivées de lettres dans un jeu de
transparence et de superposition Cédric
Guess livre son interprétation de la
nature morte en aquarelle dans une
exposition intitulée ville Blueman fleur
sauvage
dans une pratique du graphique très
ancienne ça fait vraiment longtemps que
j'en fais pour moi finalement graffiti
c'est un prétexte pour être à
l'extérieur un baladé et j'ai commencé à
mieux regarder j'estime ce qui avait
enfin ce qu'il y a autour de moi ça peut
être des grillages pour nous empêcher de
rentrer dans certains endroits et
surtout tout ce qui est végétation folle
Cédric Guess aime varier les supports et
les techniques ces premières peintures à
la bombe il les réalise dans les années
90 depuis seul ou en équipe il continue
à explorer friché entrepôt à l'abandon
pour peindre
mais peu à peu il se détache des codes
habituels du graffiti et fait évoluer
ses lettrages vers des formes abstraites
souvent dans les livres et je vais dans
des expositions de peinture très
régulièrement je regarde je regarde tout
ce qui se fait et tout ce qui s'est fait
alors ça peut aller du paysage
abstrait comme Kandinsky a pu faire
jusqu'à des travaux plus conceptuels
tout m'intéresse dans l'art voilà c'est
en fait le graffiti ça a été une porte
d'entrée dans le dans l'art pour moi
c'est
comme une petite porte dérobée
moi j'ai toujours entendu dire que le
graphiste un espace d'expression libre
donc je veux pas qu'on me mette de
contraintes donc je fais ce que je veux
comme je si c'est trop équilibré ça me
plaît pas trop donc ce que j'aime bien
faire c'est des compositions qui sont
déséquilibrées des croquis réaliser chez
lui peint sur les murs puis repris sur
papier entouré de fleurs le travail de
Cédric Guess procède d'un aller-retour
entre les lieux et les techniques des
techniques comme l'aquarelle qu'il a
donc été seul l'aquarelle c'est le
premier trait et le dernier il y a pas
de retouche possible on n'est pas sûr de
l'acrylique ou de l'huile donc ça c'est
quelque chose qui me plaît assez en
rapport avec une activité que à
l'extérieur de graffiti par exemple moi
j'aime bien que mon geste premier soit
le dernier moi ce qui m'intéresse aussi
c'est blanc de la feuille
assez saturé mais j'en ai enfin j'en ai
fait pas mal où j'essaie justement de de
faire en sorte qu'il y ait du blanc
parce que du blanc
vient la lumière quoi que j'aime bien
aussi ce côté un peu désuet de
l'aquarelle parce que généralement c'est
associé bon nature morte que j'adore
mais c'est aussi au marine et finalement
des
de la peinture plus de type folklorique
ou artisanal en fait voilà et moi j'aime
bien ouais c'est ce côté-là que j'aime
bien après l'exposition ville Blumen
l'artiste sera de retour à la galerie
Vessière de Tours cet été pour une
exposition collective